it's a terrific honor to be recognized
by a Nobel Prize this year we have three
Nobel laureates in physiology or
medicine and the emphasis as the Nobel
Committee mentioned in their
announcement is on the physiology but
also the medicine this is a basic
science prize and it recognizes
fundamental research whose medical
implications are not immediate they will
happen some of them are already
happening but what it really does is it
celebrates the importance of
understanding the life process by in and
of itself now that that focused on the
importance of fundamental research in
this case in the life sciences is
something that the Nobel Prize
contributes importantly to because
oftentimes this type of work goes less
notice than the next momentary medical
advance or clinical trial and funding
for basic science research around the
world is in serious jeopardy
particularly in the United States but
not only in the United States and
certain parts of Europe and even here in
Sweden it's although there is good
funding for basic research it could be
better and and so it's it's it's really
important that the type of work that we
represent and what we represent is just
the tip of an iceberg and there are many
other tips and it's great when these
tips of the iceberg are recognized from
time to time